when you were locked up did you hear
about um when greo and RJ took over the
novo and those are like the legend
blacks no but I'm saying this RJ no hey
greo RJ Draco no greo RJ Draco Conrad
from the ab um B sad 1900 I got a song
with be sad um just people like Pac-Man
The Gun Man from OTR you know I'm saying
shout out like X Lord like those are
just dudes that are just like really
good at rapping just do such non salant
like zo shout out to zo zo s's the best
yeah zo's fire zo's my boy and I'm just
saying cuz my friend he's just like all
around he got that it Factor no zo I
want to be more like zo I really do the
way he carries himself but the essay
version I don't think I'll ever be like
that he's just that he's just that guy
man I'm just [__] stupid and kto and
just turned up and just like baz s just
got it all in one package and just
carries it like humble just player about
it you know what I'm saying just me like
I'm just I just go with the flow B just
like every beat he gets on his West
Coast La Street like he made some
bangers right he hit him with that
underrated like I would put money on him
that he'll beat me right with the
underrated that that song was it dog
that song took over La for a minute like
he did some legendary things with him I
got songs with Zama yeah like I talk to
him every day I'm on his page right now
like that's the homie he's like my
friend yeah I don't never put him in a
competition cuz he's already like that's
my boy already like he's just like man I
throw him first every time on the set
how I was going to say uh how much of
like you honing your rap skills happened
while you were incarcerated or were you
rapping prior to you getting locked up
when you were 18 like cuz you're really
good at rapping you're not like you know
like you really are dope were you were
you like rapping a lot in jail like I
freestyle my [__] but that's what I'm
saying like that you you you're really
good at that so I'm assuming were you
getting your reps up while you were in
in in prison like just rapping in yeah
but I ran out of those songs ASAP so to
whoever whoever wants to rap like don't
use those first raps on like the worst
beat when you get out your your best
bangers don't use them on a beat that
you didn't [__] fully invest in that
you didn't write it to cuz if you're in
jail I wrote no I write raps in jail
with my head without a beat without a
beat or I remember a song on the radio
like like the it be in your head it'll
be in my head I could remember real
[__] well that be like what this
bootle K up in this [__] and I'm a
knock out call me left the gun plate I
don't [__] with dropouts so just I'll
write it in there and I'll make it and
I'll just go back and forth it's just
crazy in the writing process writing a
song it's just I wrote all my songs and
I memorize them after the first try but
there's these one songs like you write
in their bangers and when you get stuck
on a rap song If you ever made a rap
song and you don't buy your stuff you
make a rap song when you get stuck you
get stuck forever huh cash you get stuck
huh when you get stuck writing a song
you get stuck forever you never get past
that being stuck par huh you're so stuck
you erase it like a thousand times like
with a certain song that's why I
freestyle now
just off the top cuz the first one's the
best one not anybody can do that anymore
either man that freestyle [__] is a real
gift it's like told me out the they're
going to throw me on the tler CER yeah
I'm going to go against the best uh
Toppers no I'm going to win it I'm not
going to be part of it we're going to
win it La lefty gun play is it a
competition it's a competition why would
you want to lose the dard cipher I
didn't I didn't know I thought it was
just everybody was rapping n hell no
they pick a winner do they yeah did you
see the little white dude who who did it
little SE though I se when Tut G won in
from OT and he beat M for uh shout out
so and K bz and and you know tut2 G in
San Diego won that's for OTR I seen that
one how did you uh that's one of my
favorite videos Man shout out shout out
22 G man that song Hard it's a repeat
you got to look it up on the dard cipher
it's called 22 G F dard Cipher or M for
you heard M for L he hard too I was
going to get a feature with him he hard
too he those guys could sing man both of
them man one's black ones like Filipino
essay I don't know what he he he on
black ones like you know and they're
both the best singers ever I remember
asking him like hey man how do you learn
how to sing on 22 G he's just like I
just [__] shoot
it hey I thought I was in trouble he's
all I asked G I told him what's up man
at the little weirdo concert I walked up
to him before i s with OTR I said man
you sing hard man and I'm serious I'm
just like you got any tips for how to
sing better and he's just like I just do
that [__] fool I'm just what the [__]
like damn like that's a lefty answer but
it was just like he was just cocky like
I just do it and it's just true you just
do it you can look up on Google find
Tips but if you know how to sing you're
talented you know how to sing dog for
sure you know what I'm saying I want I
want to I want to sing I I want to sing
and I just think that's s said flowing
gang [__] and it just so you're going to
start singing eventually I've been
singing if you don't pay